[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to my show so
this
is sponsored um and powered by iconplus
so really quick news announcement for
you so
icon loop and the seoul government have
announced the mass
implementation of blockchain based
contactless online
reservations for more than seven
thousand public services so always
really interesting news coming out from
icon there
now as you know as always it is also i'm
sponsored by blockbuy
so um you can actually on up to 8.6
interest on your on your uscc
i use them and if you follow the link
there's a link somewhere maybe scrolling
at the bottom
you can actually get up to 250 when you
sign up
now guys if you are watching on youtube
please don't forget to hit the like
button and hit subscribe so you never
miss any of these fantastic guests
now joining me today i'm really excited
we don't know each other very well
so we're gonna get to know each other
and it's gonna be really fun so joining
me today is the cio
and the founder of block tower capital
it is
ari paul ari what's up how you doing
doing well how are you
yeah i'm good i'm good we tried to sort
of get to know each other a little bit
before but we had some internet issues
so
here we are so where where are you based
uh well today i'm in new york but um our
whole firm's going to be in miami in a
couple months and we've been
with covid we've been pretty spread out
and decentralized
yeah i think this whole covert thing is
just insane because
i feel like our industry is the only
industry
which has really kind of found its way
you know we've been able to shine we've
been able to continue working we've been
able to
you know just do what we do best
yeah the the one thing missing um and
and i say missing
you know kind of half this issue half
facetiously are the uh
just the conference circuit which was
such a big part of the 2017 experience
um
i had very mixed feelings about it i'm
an introvert i always found the
conference is exhausting even when
they're fun and exciting and
and it's great energy and great people i
still like three hours and i'm i'm toast
so
um i i'm kind of happy to be missing
that on the other hand
it it there is a little the the energy
is amazing when you've got
2 000 people who are just religious
fanatics you know it's almost like a
sporting event
yeah i know what you mean it's one of
the things that i really miss but it's
something i keep hearing from introverts
like yourself
say oh well you know i haven't had to
socialize you know i don't have to do
this i don't have to do that
but there is a conference in miami you
said you're going to go
down to miami are you going to be at the
conference in june yeah i think it seems
like everyone's going to be there
um i think there's a bit of pent-up
demand to meet in person
so i will be there uh yeah i'm sure
it'll be
an exhausting whirlwind but also a lot
of fun
yeah absolutely so i want to go back a
bit and understand a little bit about
who you are um how you got into this
space so
for those that don't know who ahri is
how would you describe yourself
um i'm an investing geek uh i i
love thinking about kind of economic
history and history of markets and
cryptocurrency is such a fascinating
petri dish where it's like we actually
get to see the birth of a new asset
class
the growth and mature maturation of
markets um so i was a trader at cisco
international group at the start of my
career then i was an
uh allocator at the chicago endowment
which is an 8 billion
endowment kind of long-term investing um
so yeah i came from kind of both ends of
traditional finance short-term trading
long-term investing and then in 2017
launched block tower and have been
all in as an understatement on crypto uh
24 7 markets
you know i i do not have a life outside
of my job and this market
but you know dedicating your like
you don't have a life outside of it so
dedicating your life to the space
something which is so new takes so much
conviction and so much passion so
how did you initially hear about bitcoin
because i saw an interview that you did
and you said when you first heard about
it you were like nah this is this is
this isn't it
yeah it's i i like bringing this up
every once in a while it's just a
reminder to be
to be humble and understanding of people
who take a while to come around to it so
my
the first uh reference i can find in my
email to coin was a friend telling me to
buy it or at least look at it in 2011.
and i didn't even remember like when i
launched block tower in 2017 i didn't
remember
ever getting that email this was just
like i searched my inbox for the first
reference and
my response to my friend um was
cryptocurrency will never have value
because value comes from either a
long-term societal appreciation like
gold or fiat backed by guns
so that was my categorical dismissal the
crypto will never be
you know worth anything in 2011. um and
then it wasn't until 2014 that i bought
bitcoin and i wasn't
a convert at that point i i dabbled and
then i kind of just gradually fell down
the rabbit hole
um spent hundreds of hours learning each
of the pieces you know the basics of
i i don't even want to say i know the
basics of cryptography because i don't
but i know
enough to understand how cryptography
works in crypto and i know enough about
blockchain engineering to know
that piece of the puzzle um so i think
for a lot of people in crypto
most people are initially dismissive
including i mean some of the core devs
like um
gregory maxwell is one of the most uh
prominent bitcoin core developers and he
famously in the very beginning on
one of the initial bitcoin kind of
discussion forums said this
doesn't work it's not byzantine fault
tolerant so you know yeah
everyone i think adam back was the same
who's the founder of block stream
and oh i didn't know he was the same i
didn't know adam back
yeah in the very beginning he was scout
i mean both of those guys have been
in since i don't know i think 2010 so
this isn't meant to insult them at all
it's more it's the opposite it's just
you know even the people who built
bitcoin
um basically everyone's initially
skeptical and then you have to kind of
unwrap the pieces to understand how they
all work together and that this does
and part of the reason is that um there
is no magic bullet with bitcoin so it's
not like there's a single thing
that solves a critical problem in an
obvious way so like
maxwell's initial objection was uh it
actually bitcoin doesn't solve the game
theory problem it's not actually
byzantine fault tolerant it doesn't
perfectly coordinate and ensure finality
and
uh security and all these things but
it's practically byzantine fault
tolerance
probabilistically fault tolerant and so
it requires a little bit of this real
world application to say
like maybe this will work in the wild
and then we and then we see proof
you know we see it in the wild we see
proof of concept we see that proof of
work has
you know worked for 11 years now or uh
yeah eleven years
almost twelve twelve eleven basically
twelve
so wait so twelve years so what was that
right
twelve eleven because you've got yeah
you've got the the white paper and then
the genesis blocking us on but when was
that
aha moment because i think i think
you're totally right that everybody
straight away is just like gosh i'm
really skeptical of this
um i mean just thinking back the first
time i'd heard of bitcoin was honestly
because
um somebody i knew was buying drugs
online
um and from silk road and that's just
that's just the harsh reality of it and
that was back in 2013
so and it took years later until i even
invested or took an
interest in it to be honest so what was
your aha moment
i i really didn't have a single moment
um it's not unusual
generally new technology um it gets
adopted by pull
and usually the pull is if it's
something disruptive it's often people
who
are not served by the trade by whatever
existed before and those are often
fringe communities or illegal or
marginalized communities um so not not
at all surprising that bitcoin's kind of
first proof concept would be
would be drugs something that
traditional banking you know isn't gonna
isn't going to knowingly support um i
say that banks pay fines every year for
knowingly supporting drug trafficking so
they do know that they supported
hey get out hsbc um so i don't yeah i
don't think it was a single moment it
was um
i was looking for something like bitcoin
because i thought basically after the
financial crisis since 2009
central banks around the world are
printing so much fiat eventually this is
going to be inflationary
what is like i i was actively i i really
wanted to financially bet
on currency depreciation and i so i was
looking for
something like bitcoin but even when i
saw bitcoin it didn't like really click
that this was the thing
the thing for me i think it was really
just putting these pieces together and
answering the objections
so when i first looked at like there are
a lot of legitimate criticisms of
bitcoin
i i say legitimate in the sense that
they require a lot of work to overcome
so you have the game theory stuff like
does proof of work like if i looked at
proof of work
like before bitcoin existed i would
probably say this won't work you know
um and then on the you know all these
pieces you have to know enough about the
cryptography to understand why it's
secure um
even the legal regulatory side like
understanding why
it's not easy for like coin center does
great work on this
and they argue that it's
unconstitutional for the us to just ban
bitcoin
um and so having an understanding that
like why is that why is that because of
a freedom of speech standpoint in terms
of the freedom to express how
what you want to buy like that um uh
no i don't i think they they may make
that argument for the first apologies to
coin center because i'm whatever i say
is going to be a horrible
uh if not a misrepresentation at least
certainly far less articulate
than than they were things um but it no
one of the arguments is
um governments can't well i shouldn't
say governments the us government can't
arbitrarily
uh dictate what we can buy and sell so
the idea of
like one of the clauses in the
constitution is those rights not
explicitly delegated to the federal
government or reserve to the states so
the federal government
um it basically needs a compelling
reason to be able to
tell you what you can do and that reason
is very very broad basically the federal
government can regulate interstate
commerce which gets used as a catch-all
but
um they've argued that god
i'm really not going to do this justice
um it's okay
i'm actually writing this down i'm
actually writing this round because i
really want to i'm literally i've got
this written down so unconstitutional
what was the company you said that spoke
about it oh well coin center
they're a non-profit lobbying group that
is plays a really important role in our
industry
um they they're kind of the non-profit
lobbying group they're definitely others
but they're they're the prominent ones
and it's it's
run by jerry britto and um peter van
walkenburg
uh and they they advocate for
cryptocurrency
as sophisticated lawyers so they're
constantly writing legal arguments they
they present those to judges to
legislators they act as lobbyists
uh to promote good legislation and
oppose bad stuff and they provide
um legal fodder for lawyers who are
going to be
defending any crypto startup for example
so when the sec
is uh making broad you know very broad
statements about icos for example coin
center will issue
very detailed legal briefs in response
and say you know or actually a great
example of this was um
when the treasury department in december
was when they when they had their
proposed fincen rule uh by steven
mnuchin the treasury secretary
coin center responded something like two
weeks later with a 70 page brief
uh kind of dissecting it and saying we
think this is illegal for like 19
different reasons
it was and it was it was actually
amazing the list of things that they
claimed uh
the the proposal violated and from
memory a few of them were like
the proposed rulemaking process was was
illegally short
and they and it was um they didn't leave
proper time for comments and
consideration
and it was and the fact that it was
rushed violated a few different
ordinances
and um and they felt it violated uh
what is it a fourth amendment basically
the the privacy penumbra because there
was no compelling reason for the
information they were
demanding the coinbase turnover to
fincen um so just this long list of
objections
that's really interesting i actually had
no idea that there was an objection that
banning
obviously as a british person i had no
idea that banning bitcoin could
potentially be
unconstitutional i need to look into
that that's that's really interesting
but just on this topic then i kind of
wanted to wait a little bit until we we
delved
into it but here we are i really want to
talk to you about energy
because this is something which has just
been going on so much
from nfts to bitcoin every single day
and this is getting really political as
well um every single day
um you know let's take the guardian for
example that's a really left-wing
newspaper in the uk
and they're constantly talking about how
the energy consumption of bitcoin is
just
insane so how how do you address that
because i've seen a lot of
articles about it and i've seen a lot of
people talk about renewable energy and
actually how bitcoin
is more to do with cleaner energy but i
honestly don't fully understand so i
would love for you to just explain this
sure um i nick carter has done some
great work nick uh
is a fun manager in the space and and uh
an excellent writer
he's written the closest that we have to
kind of the definitive rebuttal on this
um
and if you just google search nick
carter and it's nick nic
um nick carter bitcoin energy a bunch of
his essays will pop up
um it's a frankly it's a fairly
simple set of arguments um
so okay uh electricity is hard to move
from place to place
so recently in the us we had people uh
freezing in texas
due to electricity shortage even while
we had plenty of electricity
on the east coast and us it's really
hard to move electricity a long distance
and
people don't know i i was an electricity
trader briefly at cisco international
group
and i traded among other things texas
electricity
and the first thing you learn as an
electricity trader is the u.s
and the world have very very separate
electricity markets and electricity
doesn't really flow between them only
there's basically like these tiny
connections between
texas is known as ercot that's the name
of the power grid uh
the northeast has something called pjm
which is an acronym for pennsylvania new
jersey and maryland
and those are distinct energy grids and
very very little electricity can move
across them um that's not by the way
necessarily
always going to be true you can build uh
kind of the right kinds of power lines
to move a lot of power but the world
basically hasn't the us certainly hasn't
so um so okay part of the reason this is
a complex topic is just there's
it's not rocket science but there's a
lot of this kind of like specific info
that
people aren't familiar with you know um
okay
so hard to move power place to place
almost all
other electricity demand is local in the
sense that you typically need your power
plant and
your generator uh right near an
industrial center you'd be because it's
hard to move electricity long distance
where does electricity get gets you get
used it gets used by factories and by
urban centers
so bitcoin's the exception bitcoin you
really you can have a giant bitcoin
mining farm with three employees
so you can build that anywhere in the
world and so what happens is the
cheapest electricity tends to be in very
remote places
and it tends to be renewable so things
like uh geothermal
in iceland and scandinavia hydroelectric
power in the pacific northwest as well
as northwest china
um renewables and like wind farms solar
farms uh they're cheapest to build where
there's no people where land is very
very cheap
so what what's been happening is every
year
more and more of bitcoin's mining power
comes from renewables
and it incentivizes research and
renewables because it's an
arms race it's a hyper competitive
competition among people to find the
cheapest source of power anywhere in the
world
and it happens that the innovation is
really happening in the on the renewable
side
coal isn't really getting any cheaper
and it's happening in far-flung remote
areas
so that's the renewable bit coming in
i'm missing that bit where's the
renewable bit coming in
so the distinction is that with fossil
fuels uh
they kind of are where they are so the
coal deposits will be wherever they are
um the uh
well so it's two things one it's
location a lot of the renewables
are by far cheapest in very remote
places where they're not attractive to
traditional industry
so solar and wind are just a great
example where like solar panels take up
a huge amount of physical space
you're not going to build a giant solar
farm outside of new york city because
the land's too expensive right
so the place basically this is the use
case
where renewables are naturally the most
competitive that
makes bitcoin one of the first kind of
general adopters of renewable energy at
giant scale
and and you get economies of scale you
get efficiency and so when you have a
lot of people around the world investing
hundreds of millions of dollars in
trying to build the most competitive
bitcoin mining farm they can
that's a lot of money getting put into
renewables research and even just
economies of scale so for example like
photo photovoltaic cells solar panels
um they're much cheaper the more you
make of them and so the problem
historically has been this is part of
the reason why governments
will you know try to subsidize renewable
energy uh one of the economic reasons is
okay if you build one solar panel it's
crazy expensive and it's super
uncompetitive
but if you build a million of them it's
actually only a little bit
more expensive than oil and so if the
government subsidizes to get to a
certain scale
then it actually doesn't need to be that
big of a subsidy because solar panels
aren't that
uncompetitive at scale and in a few
years solar panels are actually going to
be cheaper than oil in many parts of the
world
um and when i say a few years i don't
i'm not in the weeds on exactly how long
but
like a lot of energy experts are
projecting five to ten years until solar
panels generally are just cheaper
as a source of energy than oil so this
is a temporary problem
in 10 years bitcoin is almost certainly
going to be mostly renewable energy
and i actually think it's a positive
environmentally because it pushes for
innovation
in renewables in a way that is then
going to cause even industrial centers
to use more renewable energy
okay so firstly thank you for that that
was actually really helpful that
actually was like really really super
helpful
but given that okay i've got it now but
why is this so difficult for
people to jump on board with do you
think that it's actually not that
difficult for them to understand
it's more just they don't like it it
doesn't fit the narrative
um bitcoin is too disruptive so let's
just find some fud
and yeah i think it's largely look for
for the audience of those articles i
don't fault a reader because
um but nothing i said was that
complicated but it was
a little bit of quirky knowledge that
most people don't have like most people
don't know how electrical grids work
right you know like why would you why
would you know that so
um for the readers of the articles i
think they they're just getting fooled
by bad journalism
the journalists um have a very clear
it's just such a simple easy headline in
narrative
right it's it's something that sells
papers it's a
it it feels moralistic it makes the
journalist feel good it makes the reader
feel good
right you get to feel smug and superior
and if people are making money on this
thing
um i mean bitcoin is is such an
attractive populist whipping boy
i think we are going to see more
pushback um
in that look no one um who's a more
hateable group
than the crypto rich right you've got a
bunch of uh
frankly largely at least in the western
hemisphere largely
white dudes the whole you know bitcoin
bro idea
um there's some truth to that in the
sense that you know
the the crypto community in the western
hemisphere is
it it combines all of the negative
demographics of its pieces so like the
trading industry
is male dominated and white dominated
and computer science
is male and white and cryptography is
male and white
uh and so it's not a surprise that
cryptocurrency which is kind of the
intersection of those things would
you know be more that so you've got um
young people
who are getting stupidly rich without
much effort
and you know crypto people they like to
talk about oh it's so hard to huddle
don't tell me that it's like easy to you
know
survive these massive swings and we've
earned our 100 x's
it's like to me that's so insulting to
an entrepreneur who worked three jobs to
like
buy a house you know i mean like i'm not
saying it's easy
to huddle through an eighty percent dip
but
normally in life through it you could
sleep through it but you couldn't sleep
through
building a company basically right
people don't usually like in in
life people don't usually make millions
of dollars tens of millions of dollars
by not clicking a button right it
usually a lot more work goes into
making 10 million dollars so you know
you've got young people who are
um like a a a an easy demographic to
attack who got rich without trying
it's just a very attractive kind of
populist target right it feels like
undeserved wealth and so
tacking on any other moralistic things
tacking on the environmental stuff
tacking on
um i think fairly soon we'll start
seeing wealth inequality arguments you
know we'll start hearing
uh from the progressive side like you
know slap a one-time wealth tax on
bitcoiners
the same way it's like tax billionaires
well at least most well not
i don't know about most but you know
plenty of the billionaires people are
talking about swapping a wealth tax on
actually built companies of tremendous
value to the world you know and and
you take someone like a bezos and i'm
not personally a big fan of facebook
or zuckerberg but like zuckerberg's a
billionaire because he built something
that people like using
right and he built it over you know more
than a decade and
and built it out competed everyone and
so say what you will he at least worked
for it you know
um and gave the world something the
world wanted whether the world should
have wanted it or not
um so yeah i i think we should be we
should expect more attacks
and that's just life i hate that
narrative
so much i hate the narrative of like
hate billionaires tax billionaires more
because it's just like then stop using
their products if you hate them so much
like just just give it up um i hate it
it really disincentivizes people to
want to actually make something of
themselves but just that narrative there
as well is really interesting
because that it's you know it's for you
know the white men's rich trading club
or whatever
because there's a huge um niche within
cryptocurrency which is
actually not even a niche to be honest
um which is actually it's helped so many
people
from really terrible backgrounds turn
their entire lives around
um whether it be in trading just buying
bitcoin
or whatever it is i mean there's even
isaiah jackson who
um has the book um i think it's um was
it
bitcoin bit oh god what is that black
bitcoin
what's it called i can't remember yeah
i'm blanking on the name uh but i i know
you're
pointing on black america maybe it's
bitcoin and black america i think that's
the name
yeah and he and he talks about um how
black people
should get reparations in bitcoin and
that is just completely contradictory to
the narrative that i guess
they want you to believe um so i mean
even even for me i'm in my 20s
and i'm so grateful for bitcoin because
i've been able to
turn a lot of things around and you know
i don't have to now think
oh gosh inflation how on earth did i now
you know invest in the stock market
like i now need to you know run a job
run this
run that and also learn how to trade and
invest and all that but you know
my generation has bitcoin um something
that you know didn't have before
yeah it is a generational wealth
transfer um and
agree that it is democratizing um
in many ways and it creates huge amounts
of entrepreneurial opportunity for
people who are i mean there's so many
uh young people with no resume who've
been able to create successful companies
in the industry right just because it's
it's so new that there
can't have a pedigree so definitely
agree with that and i'm i'm also a huge
believer in the humanitarian benefits i
just think it's not
it's not quite the progressive liberal
kind of uh
agenda it's it's a much more um
libertarian one in the sense that
i love it like yeah so part of what
first drew me to bitcoin was the idea
that
people can flee a totalitarian state
with their wealth now
so like i had relatives some who fled
nazi germany some who didn't
and to to anyone in a totalitarian state
whether it's nazi germany kimmer rouge
um
frankly china today you kind of have a
choice you can usually escape
a totalitarian regime with the shirt on
your back like it's usually on in most
of these examples
there was kind of at least a window
before the border closed when you could
have fled
but you would have been fleeing into
poverty right if you were a middle class
cambodian or
jew or a hong kong resident
if your choice is go to european refugee
camp for years
abandon your livelihood your family you
know basically thrust your family into
extreme poverty
or take your you know roll the dice that
this totalitarian regime will hopefully
revert to
you know the country that you've lived
in and love and and that you you know
you hopefully can trust your neighbors
um a lot of people stay whereas if you
could leave
and being able to flee the country just
you know with a password in your head
you could take your wealth with you um
i think it it is an incredible weapon
against totalitarianism
it's going to allow people in general to
flee totalitarian states with their
wealth faster more aggressively that
undercuts the totalitarian state itself
because it pulls wealth out of the
country
um so it it it's yeah i'm a huge
believer in cryptocurrency from the
human rights perspective
but it's not a wealth equalizer it's not
like
a lower middle-class person in america
is automatically going to close the gap
with billionaires because of bitcoin
so it's it's humanitarian in helping the
worst off in the world
the people who truly truly are oppressed
not the people who
are just unhappy with the wealth and
equality yeah and i think
that's such an interesting point you
know in terms of fleeing
um fleeing these regimes because
just back to nazi germany jews were
swallowing gold
when they had that time when they had
that gap when
you know people knew something was i
think after like crystal nuts or
whatever it was like after
that people had that gap and they knew
get your papers and go
they were swallowing gold i can't
remember whether it's in the film i
can't remember i was watching shin as
list but i don't know if the scene is in
that or not i can't remember or whether
it's a museum but i just remember seeing
a picture of people swallowing gold and
just thinking wow
like that's insane like the portability
of bitcoin you know
yeah yeah and uh gold precious uh
precious jewels
um i have a friend whose family fled
from cambodia with a piece of jade
and that piece of jade was the start of
their life in canada
what's jade forgive me i don't know what
jade is oh it's uh it's a stone
that is very precious particularly in
asian cultures
um i i think it's it's mostly mined in
asia but it's just also very culturally
significant um
i i feel bad saying asia i'm just very
ignorant of i know it's uh part of
chinese culture i don't know if it's
other part of
other asian countries so i'm ignorant
but the moral of the story was
this rock was the key to them escaping
with wealth
um but yeah i mean obviously
cryptocurrency is infinitely better
you're not having quarter guards check
your stool if you're right swallowing
gold is certainly not ideal
no it's not ideal but you know it was
done but
okay so you're obviously really into
bitcoin your perception changed you've
dedicated your um your now career to all
of this
um but i know that you're not a bitcoin
maximalist
um so i do want to talk about that
because that's something that i'm kind
of um
navigating actually at the moment and
it's all really interesting what's
happening particularly with defy
ethereum okay so i'm not going to ask
you what are your thoughts because
that's just a terrible question
yeah but i wanna kind of okay tell me
where where do you draw that line
between a coin
and bitcoin that's my question so i
think
to to me uh it's actually very
frustrating because the
trying to debate the no coiners like
nouriel roubini or peter schiff
is frustrating because they make such
simply wrong statements
and so everyone in crypto gets
frustrated like roubini will say
you know it's tulips it's a bubble and
then it's like well you've been saying
that for seven years
and the tulip bubble lasted eight months
and tulips weren't programmable
censorship resistant depreciation
resistant provably scarce like it's a
terrible analogy and you're just wrong
and you
you keep being wrong um and then say you
know same with like roubini five years
ago was saying well
uh there's no institutional adoption
well yeah it was too early
and now we see it right so so all those
arguments are just
um they're obviously either unfair and
that it's just too early you know
someone's saying the first year bitcoin
was created this isn't accepted by
merchants worldwide therefore it's a
failure it's like
it's been around for a year like this is
like female in 1974 right
so i find the bitcoin maximalist
arguments
identical and it's weird in that
literally
the arguments are almost word for word
the same as norio roubini's
the anti-bitcoin arguments are identical
to the anti-shit coin arguments
to the word if you replace bitcoin with
ethereum let's say
so the maximalist arguments when i got
in this industry really
five years ago were uh anything that you
want to do in crypto you can do on
bitcoin
yeah that was a big one and my answer
and at the time there wasn't that much
being done in crypto right dfi didn't
exist yet nfts didn't exist yet um
you really didn't have much happening
like there wasn't you couldn't use
crypto for much other than simple story
value and payments
so it wasn't obviously wrong but my i i
said i bet you're going to be wrong
maybe eventually you're right maybe in
five 10 years bitcoin will evolve to be
able to offer anything but
there's gonna be a huge amount of time
where bitcoin is optimizing for
stability and security
meaning it's gonna it's to the extent it
evolves at all it's gonna evolve very
slowly
and eventually we may get everything we
want via layer twos but
certainly in 2016 2017 there was nothing
like that on the horizon
and now we've seen the the
maximum argument was wrong in that
there's a lot of stuff you can you that
people value and can't do on bitcoin so
today um it's still the same arguments
the maximalist will still say well you
could in theory do d5 and bitcoin you
could in theory do nfts on bitcoin
and it's like well sure but you can't
and eventually maybe you will be able to
and great like that's the nature it's
almost like saying like
amazon has no value because in theory
jpmorgan chase could
evolve to do the same thing as them well
great like let's
let's talk in 10 years like okay if you
know but amazon clearly has value today
so there's incredibly uh
there's incredible adoption and usage of
d5 and nfts today there's more than 100
000 owners of topshop for example those
are
largely people who've never touched any
other cryptocurrency
and bought uh mba collectibles on the
flow blockchain
those don't exist on bitcoin maybe
someday they will but
in the interim people are getting value
from flow they're getting value from
uh mba top shots similarly with defy
eventually maybe this will be on bitcoin
but
for the time being people are getting
value from defy on ethereum
so we see the product market fit we see
the adoption we see the usage and we see
that we can get stuff people want
uh with provable product market fit on
platforms other than bitcoin
so the maximalists are just wrong
they've been wrong for five years um
when they mock icos they've been wrong
like
you know the no coiners when bitcoin
dips from
60k to 50k they're like see we were
right it's a bubble
crash right and it's like well you've
been saying that since bitcoin was 100
so no you're not right because it dipped
so the the maximalists say the same
thing when an ico fails it's like
oh one ico failed icos in general have
made investors tons of money they've
outperformed bitcoin
um an investor you know people who've
been calling ethereum scam since 2014
they're like see i was right because
bitcoins ethereum's underperformed
bitcoin for the last six months it's
like
no you weren't right if you put one
bitcoin into the ethereum ico
um i believe it would now be worth 3.6
million dollars you would have made
more than 40x your bitcoin so
um there there's a
because i'm quite i'm quite direct with
things so this is just the way my mind
works but whatever
so of course you've got the likes of
adam back who you know they know what
they're talking about they're fantastic
but i'm outside of those um let's call
them pioneers
outside of these kind of people you have
people just in the community and do you
find
that there's a lot of bitcoin maximalism
potentially comes from the fact
that they maybe don't understand defy or
don't haven't done enough
research and it's kind of easier just to
sort of
um you know push something aside and
disregard it and just
find let's say home in a community and
find protection in a community
rather than being brave enough to
potentially
um you know think actually hang on
people
can you know take out loans and
mortgages in
countries that don't have any financial
infrastructure
what do you think i i think it really
varies by person
uh some of some there are some
maximalists who are very informed and
educated about everything else
and for some of them um it comes from
basically there are a lot of coins
there are true coins that are
outright scams that are rug you know rug
pull is it
some of them are true scams there's a
lot of those right people who are
intentionally scamming by icos or
new coin launches there's a lot of that
and then some of them are accidental
scams
where you know you've got a couple kids
they might be well intentioned they
don't know what they don't know
and so like uh some of the people who
criticize ethereum
will say okay maybe it's not a
deliberate scam but they think it's an
accidental scam because they think
it's um not secure enough so a common
criticism was
um ethereum intends to migrate to proof
of stake and proof of stake doesn't work
and the problem with the argument the
proof of stake doesn't work is it's the
exact same logic of the people who said
proof of work doesn't work which is on
paper it has vulnerabilities
there's no question that proof of stake
is of questionable security we don't
know that it's secure
there's known vulnerabilities but all of
that was true of proof of work
and the only reason that we trust proof
of work is not because
like that the math is perfect it's
because it works in practice
so um those same people uh including
people like greg maxwell who were
skeptical of proof of work
it's a it's the same psychology that
makes it's basically a conservative
investment investing mindset it's
you know someone comes up with something
innovative and new and cool
and you see that it's not perfect there
are holes in it legitimate legitimate
vulnerabilities
and so one type of person says this is
innovation
right and and they're not going to get
it perfect on the first try it's going
to be
you know a work in progress and other
people say
this thing isn't perfect and it's trying
to take on my beloved bitcoin
it's it's trash it's garbage it's you
know it's fundamentally flawed
so you know if you view this as a work
in progress um
it's much easier to be kind of tolerant
of the experimentation and the foibles
and
i view this industry much more through
the vc lens which is
you don't expect anything to be right on
the first try you expect teams to pivot
you expect the engineering to evolve
over time
um so that's that's a big part of it and
then i think another part is um
some people so the same way that a
roubini a no coiner will point at
the long tail of scam cryptocurrencies
and say all cryptocurrencies are bad
look at all these ico scams bitcoin is a
scam too it's tainted by association
a lot of the maximalists apply the exact
same thinking
right they just exclude bitcoin so they
say ari i don't care if there's one or
two or five icos that are real that are
not scams that are innovative that are
interesting technology and they may have
a real use case
come on ari like 99.9 percent of this
stuff is crap
and my answer to that would be so do you
include bitcoin as part of that crap
no you carve out bitcoin you say it you
you say
just because 99.9 percent of
cryptocurrencies are crap doesn't mean
bitcoin's crap and i just go one step
further and i say just because 99.9
of cryptocurrencies crap doesn't mean
bitcoin in these 10 others
are crap so it's partly just where do
you draw the line and and your comment
about like a little bit of lack of
knowledge or intellectual laziness i
think does play a role there
it's are you willing to separate the
wheat from the chaff and bitcoiners
it's just they stop at bitcoin yeah i
mean
it's a bit of a it's a bit of a head
spin because i
i remember i put out a comment sort of
saying matt you know because there's a
lot of tribalism i put out a comment
saying
imagine not liking someone you know
personally really having a dislike to
them because they prefer a different
coin to you
and i always found i've never forgotten
the response i got to that which was
people calling the likes of
vitalik and many other people actual
scammers
um comparing them to charles ponzi
um bernie madoff and all these things
and i couldn't believe i couldn't
believe the comparison
and i think that for me was like the
first time i
really kind of like swallowed the
tribalism pill and was like
i felt that yeah i will say a lot of the
tribalism
is for show it's it's marketing and
signaling
and um because a lot of the bitcoin core
developers and self-proclaimed
maximalists actually have exposure to
other coins
many have actually launched other coins
so a huge percentage of all
cryptocurrencies have actually been
launched by bitcoin core developers
um now many of those people end up being
kind of excommunicated later
so uh whether it's the bitcoin hard
forks whether it's
um wait but i think i don't remember
charles hoskinson was a bitcoin core dev
a lot of the founders of other coins uh
decred was founded by
charles was eighth so
um i'm not sure we our viewers can check
but but uh
a lot of founders of um
let's see which other ones um i don't
know if ricardo is a bitcoin core dev
but but a lot of the monero community
was definitely bitcoin miners and early
adopters d-cred was founded by bitcoin
core devs uh
a lot of them were and um mimbo wimble
uh oh sorry
grin was founded by a current bitcoin
core developer um
which is a mimblewimble coin
implementation
sorry not number wimblecoin is its own
thing by another bitcoin og
trace meyer who was showing it um but or
and then you have like i i think it's in
x token uh a bunch of the block stream
employees launched in the erc20
equity coin and uh there's a great
example where like these are bitcoin
maximalists who call ethereum a scam
and they launched a token on ethereum
and they did that because it was the
best way to fundraise and it was the
best way to issue an equity token for
their exchange
um so a lot of it is public signaling to
build brand
and a lot of these maximalists that
monetize their brand by selling um
trading seminars and and carnivory
dinners and their books
and at the same time they're investing
uh like
uh i believe with safadeen publicly said
um
uh steven's the author of what the
bitcoin standard
and a very public and aggressive bitcoin
maximalist he invested in the ethereum
pre-sale
and he said publicly lost he lost his
keys um now he
he says now to be fair anyone can change
their mind the fact that he invested in
the ico doesn't mean he's not allowed to
then become a maximalist and
he says he then realized it was a scam
but my point is just um
most of the maximalists have exposure to
other coins
a lot of them are are trying to virtue
signal
yeah this is a really interesting point
i had a conversation with um the ceo of
uh
a company in this in the crypto space
the other day and he said that to me
he said to me leia they're all investing
in other coins and i was like
i'm i i have um i'm very i'm very honest
person so what you see is what you get
with me
i'm very straight up so to me the idea
that you know you have people talking
about bitcoin only
and then they are in using times like
coins and they're actually
investing in other things i
really took me back i couldn't believe
it um so i'm really fascinated by that i
think that's really interesting
um but let's talk about nfts because
nfts are really hot right now
and there's two things going on here
from my um from my perspective
so we've got this supposed bubble right
whereby if something is just inherently
an nft
then you know eventually it will be you
know invest now because
it's the next big thing it's the uber
it's whatever it is it's facebook
but then also so there's that which i'm
not really interested in
but then there's also just the idea of
um giving something
a digital identity and verifying it and
for me
that is really powerful for example um
you know rolex watches louis vuitton
handbags
being able to literally track where it
came from so my brother's really into
rolex watches
and he's telling me that if you buy it
through this country that country then
it's actually
um less valuable if you buy it for
example he was he was telling me
oh because this watch came through dubai
it's actually less valuable than the
same rolex watch which came through
europe and stuff like that
so for that reason i'm like cool i get
it
but i i'm not i'm not understanding this
this bubble over here which is
supposedly you know buy now and then you
know sell it off later like
crypto kitties or you know swords and
this
and that that you get in games yeah um
nfts were such a no-brainer to me as a
obvious early theme for crypto one of
the first use cases to go mainstream
um for like 18 different reasons uh you
know the world
is being digital people living more and
more of their lives you know people use
crypto um
crypto punks to signal on social media
it's the modern version of having a
picasso on your wall
someone has a half million dollar crypto
punk as their twitter avatar
and now you know especially with kovid
we're all spending all our time online
we can't really show off our homes to
friends and so we're showing off our
online identities
and increasingly that's going to become
metaverse identities whether it's a
world of warcraft type game
you know people spend so much money on
skins for example and it's largely
gen z and young millennials who will
spend you know
if they're spending 30 hours a week with
their friends in a game
the idea of decorating their character
with and spending the same amount of
money that you would spend on a rolex or
a gucci handbag makes total sense
because that's your that's where your
you get to socially peacock that's where
you get to
impress your friends and show off your
taste your style um and then as you
noted there's the providence side which
is um
like a concern i personally have is if i
i haven't bought uh
almost any like high-end collectibles
and part of the reason is i'm concerned
that we're passing this point where
forgeries are indistinguishable from the
real
so every year christie's and sotheby's
gets tricked into selling
ten tens of millions of dollars of
forged art forged wine
and that's with their experts closely
examining it that you know they do
every test that they do spectrographic
tests they do you know
that's under a microscope they're
getting fooled by forgeries
so people tell me um this is a common
like debate i say on twitter
there are now rolex forgeries and gucci
handbag forgeries and picasso forgeries
that you can't distinguish from the real
thing and everyone's like no no i can
tell the difference
no you can't you could tell the
difference 20 years ago you can tell the
difference from a cheap knockoff
there are now rolexes being made and
they're not super cheap to make so if
it's a knockoff of a 20 000
rolex they cost 2 000 to make because
they're made with real materials they're
made with
like it's an it's a solid gold rolex
they just came out of a different
warehouse basically
exactly exactly they um i saw this
youtube clip of someone comparing a real
paddock uh to a knockoff including a
turbine tourbillon which i'm probably
mispronouncing which is like a really
expensive handmade
um thing that slightly increases the
precision of the time and it was a watch
enthusiast looking at both with like a
jeweler's loop and he's like i can just
barely tell the difference and it's
and both were handcrafted both were
handmade
and some of the parts probably came out
of the exact same factories
so you know so the problem is if if i
can't tell that
you know if i'm an enthusiast and i
really like let's say paddock watches
and i want to spend forty thousand
dollars on one
but i know that i can't tell the
difference between that and a 3 000
knock off
and i know that no one looking at it
will be either to either and i can't
even tell the difference
then how do i justify spending the 40k
so nfts
um now i don't think humans are going to
suddenly stop valuing authenticity
right we're still going to value
authenticity we're still going to want
to have the original the real brand item
so the only way to solve for that is
with a cryptographic signature to prove
authenticity yeah i mean
i'm just excited okay so i also agree
with you when you say everything is
going online it's an
argument that i always make right
whether it be um
dating socializing eating
um the way we order food everything is
online so it only makes
sense that you know we will move
everything online just okay
actually it's how someone explained it
to me and i thought it was really cool
so
instagram and facebook is basically like
kind of like you were saying it's how
you peacock online it's how you
show yourself off um and if you try to
explain that let's say to your
grandparents grandparents
that you would have this um version of
yourself
on the online that gives you value
supposedly
they'd be like but what about just the
value in real life you know
why do you need an online version of
yourself and i think that's where for me
i haven't taken that step in terms of
nfts because
i can't think why would i need an online
art room you know i'm just sort of
thinking why would i need that but
for some reason i feel the need to have
an online photo gallery of myself on
instagram
yeah i think um a little bit of this is
uh
it's early in that we don't really have
the metaverses yet so
we have games and and we do have stuff
like sim life
um but the reality is most people are
not spending that much time
in these non-game metaverses that's
going to change
um the technology's getting better in a
post-covered world uh you know like
there was a virtual burning man
last year there was a vr burning man
there was a vr
you know crypto conferences and they're
very basic today
but that's where the world's headed so
um yeah i do think nfts are a bubble in
the sense that
uh if you take the average nft today
it's probably worth less than a year
with that said
i so i agree with that and i wouldn't
passively buy a basket of nfts today
but um it's gonna grow horizontally 100x
in the next three years 100x and
that's such a clear bet because uh well
it's hard to bet on
um it's hard to bet on horizontal growth
in an industry but all of the ip owners
are racing to do deals so nba topshot
has been so successful for the mba
it's such a proof of a successful proof
of concept that all the other leagues
all the top musicians everyone says
holy crap these guys just minted 200
million dollars out of nowhere selling
collectibles
um you know djs like blau blah did
you know blau's been um in the in the
crypto industry for like five years uh
the guy
is a world-class dj but also has really
put in his time in crypto he's been
a passionate early adopter for i don't
know when he when he first got in but
um he was actually in our offices
pitching a startup in 2018.
um and uh he ended up calling off the
startup at least on the fundraising side
because he
ended up not loving the business model
um and i have nothing but respect for
him by the way uh
so he did 11 million dollars of sales in
one day
selling musical nfts um their their
musical with visuals um he has a graphic
designer that he works with
and every dj in the world sees that i
mean that's real money for
even the highest end performers you know
a steve aoki a
a taylor swift a beyonce the idea that
you can do 11 million dollars of sales
in a day
is meaningful numbers for every artist
and musician in the world
so um everyone's coming all the
musicians celebrities uh
sports teams athletes everyone is coming
and wants to get a piece of the demand
that they see is there
i think that's what's so insane about
2021 and this whole bull market in
general
is that it's just so different to 2017
this
this is mainstream like i got in just at
the end of 2017
and there was this constant i i used to
do hard news
basically hard crypto news and there was
this constant conversation about mass
adoption
you know like on twitter when people are
basically like making fun of something
and they do like the capital letters and
the lower letters
that's i don't that makes sense that's
how i feel about mass adoption when i
hear the word mass adoption i just hear
like mass adoption
like it's just this really cringy term
but like it is now like it's happening
now which is so insane
um to see it happening i mean even
soldier boy
just it's just you know it's just more
than 2017 so
i think it's really insane um but i want
to move on a little bit and i want to
talk um a bit about entrepreneurship um
because
block tower and so on so you guys
actually
launched in 2007 was it 2017 in the
middle of the bull market
so by the time you were sort of fully up
and running
we were in a bear market so firstly
that's insane that blew my mind when i
when i learned about that
so major congrats and how did how did
you
how did you do that like how did you how
did you as such a new company survive
just basically plunging into the bear
market because i don't think anybody
expected
a you know 20k down to three i don't
think anyone kind of expected that
yeah um frankly it was brutal as an
entrepreneur um
uh brutal and we were fortunate in that
if we hadn't launched when we did we
launched in
uh mid-august 2017 like anyone who
launched in say december
with a long bias crypto strategy almost
impossible to survive because
really in finance um you really can't
survive uh well so first a sentence on
how hedge funds work uh
for for your audience um typically
hedge funds try to get by on their
management fee so a common structure
will be something like two and twenty
meaning they charge two percent of a fee
uh you charge two percent a year on your
asset base so if you're running a
billion dollar fund that'd be 20 million
a year
and you charge carry on performance and
in traditional finance typically hedge
funds
uh pay their operating expenses with the
management fee and hope to get rich on
kerry
um in crypto it's the scale it's very
hard to get to the scale where the
management fee
covers your expenses so um i mean
a newly launched crypto fund generally
is not going to raise a billion dollars
um the only crypto funds that have gone
to a billion dollars to my knowledge
have gotten there largely organically
meaning they've they've maybe they
raised 100 million and then crypto
10x and so now they're a billion dollars
so almost everyone
basically loses money on the management
fee
we did through most of our history and
um
you really have to think of yourself
more as like a growth startup and so do
you have the capital to
finance losses for years to grow to get
to a scale
that you're a profitable enterprise so
that was how we thought of ourselves
from the beginning
um literally when we launched i told my
co-founder uh i'm probably not going to
time it perfectly but there is going to
be an 80
crash probably in the next year or two
and
our job is to survive that bear market
and if we survive it we'll be an
industry leader
because almost no one's going to survive
it and i i'm a big believer that
franchises
in finance as well as in traditional in
in any industry
get built in bear markets that's when
you step when when the going is good
there's just a lot of competition
there's a lot of faces in the crowd
there's a lot of people doing well
it's when the tide comes out you see
who's swimming without clothes
and most people give up or they they
don't have a choice they lose too much
money or their investors abandon them
so if you're able to survive that bear
market you're in a really good position
whether you're
amazon coming out of the tech crash
whether you're uh
you know a finance company um so for us
i think it was really
we expected there to be a protracted
bear market and psychologically prepared
for it financially prepared for it it's
not to say we traded it perfectly we
didn't it's not like
i timed the market you know anywhere
near perfectly at all
but just being psychologically ready um
you know like my whole team
i told them once a week guys be mentally
ready there's going to be
an 80 crash to your bear market like
we're in it for the long haul
and if you're not like you need to be
mentally prepared for this um
and then one piece of it is frankly just
um
willing to make the bet to keep going so
for uh hedge funds if you're under water
meaning if you lose money you don't get
to collect carry until your investors
are back above
the high water mark and the idea is that
you don't get to collect carry twice on
the same move
so for example if a hedge fund goes up
the year ends they get to collect carry
if it then falls a hundred percent
sorry sorry falls fifty percent and then
goes up 100 again you shouldn't get to
collect
terry a second time on that same move
right it wouldn't be fair to your
investors
so what happens in a bear market is
hedge funds are wildly underwater
they might be 30 50 70 underwater which
means
you're not really making any money until
you first earn a 200 or 300 or 400
return most hedge funds just shut down
they're like man we're not making any
money for years we have to earn a 300
return
just before we get paid a dollar why
would we stay open
so uh that happens to almost every hedge
fund in crypto if you're running any
kind of long bias strategy
you're almost certainly going to lose
money in a bear market and like
my goal is always to lose a lot less
than crypto
but um i'm actually not even trying to
make money from the decline
um i think it's too hard you can run an
absolute return or a market neutral
strategy or an arbitrage strategy that's
great but if you're trying to
capture the beta if you're trying to
capture the 10x upside
very very hard to be net short through
the bear market
so my goal is um try to outperform when
crypto's going up and then try to lose a
lot less
when crypto's going down and if you do
both those things then you end up with a
very very good return over a full cycle
but my point though is you're still
losing money in the bear market you
still need to have the fortitude the
grit
the belief that there's going to be
another bull run and you're willing to
invest
just you know to see that through yeah i
think the thing which really just stuck
out there was
the idea of just preparing not just
yourself but everyone around you the
entire team is saying guys you know this
isn't gonna this is
gonna be difficult the bear market is
coming when you know that i think it's
all about
reality isn't it just sort of having
that reality check and knowing things
don't always go up so
just hold on tight and we're in it for
the long run but
yeah but for people who okay
so i get this question a lot um and so
for people who
um aren't necessarily technical or they
don't or they don't
have an investor background like you
have an investing background like you
have
how how can they get involved like how
can they see
okay i like this space politically i'm
aligned
um what can i do to get involved as an
entrepreneur what tips would you give
them
yeah i think um the starting point is is
really
what work you want to be doing if you're
an artist getting involved in
you know creating nft art is a great
idea if you're an accountant
um applying your skill set if you're a
lawyer applying
basically all of the skill sets that
exist in the world are useful in crypto
so marketing pr hr recruiting um
you know you're an example of this where
you're you're running a business that is
not inherently a crypto business but
you're applying it to crypto right
um so it happened to be that my skill
set was trading and investing
you know i applied that to crypto but um
so i think the starting point is what is
your skill set and if you're very young
like let's say you're just coming out of
college
what what do you want to be doing with
your life what kind what's what's the
work you want to be doing
so like and i think this is a useful
exercise for anyone looking at any job
which is
there's kind of two decisions which is
what industry do you want to be in and
then what role do you want to have
so an accountant working for
uh a university uh not you know a
non-profit
an accountant working for general
electric you're still doing accounting
work
the industry matters a lot but your
day-to-day it matters more
what is your role right are you a true
like if i'm trading bitcoin or i'm
trading that gas
i'm still a trader and my day-to-day is
not that different if i don't like
trading i shouldn't be a trader it
doesn't matter what industry i'm in
same with um if you don't you know don't
be a crypto account if you don't like
accounting don't be a crypto lawyer if
you don't like
if you don't want to be a lawyer so i
think it starts with um
okay you know what industry you want to
be in but now what is your career path
and if you couldn't imagine doing it if
it wasn't crypto
it's probably not going to be a good fit
like don't become an accountant just to
become a crypto account
right if you don't like accounting it's
not gonna last um
but within that it's it's every skill
set is necessary you know
people are building uh like i'm thinking
of um
uh bobby who runs i think it's called
proof of talent which is a recruiting
firm
and it's a recruiting firm it's a
recruiting that's cool
yeah i'm pretty sure i'm getting the
name right proof of talent uh i'm
blanking on his last name but
it's very well respected well regarded
they've placed a ton of people at crypto
funds crypto firms um
uh i i don't have any connection i'm not
trying to show them or anything but um
i i've i i've only heard good things
about them and i've referred a couple
people
um to them just to be helpful uh
it's just an example where a guy said
you know i i'm a recruiter i want to
build a recruiting firm
here's a nascent industry which is going
to make it right if you're trying to
build a recruiting firm in the oil and
gas industry you're competing against
incumbents who know everyone who've been
doing it forever who have the rolodexes
very hard to start a company so but blue
ocean right bobby was able to build a
big profitable meaningful valuable
recruiting firm because it's a new
industry in crypto
yeah i think that's also something which
i can totally relate to because
you know coming into this space there's
so many opportunities and
it's so unbelievable um even just in
journalism
because the entire traditional world in
any sense
it doesn't want to change it doesn't
want to innovate it doesn't want to grow
um whereas this space everybody wants to
grow and i think it's amazing
um but just finally what are you up to
and where can people find you um just
chill yourself ari
uh i'm a nice thing is i really never
have anything to show
in that um no i mean i seriously it and
it it makes it
pleasant in that i'm just chatting with
you and offering my sincere views
because i really i don't have any i'm
not selling anything um
uh so i'm i i'm on twitter at ari david
paul
um that's how people can reach me in any
content i produce in any forum i post
there um
yeah that's it and then i will probably
be in uh in miami for the bitcoin
conference and i will be in miami after
that generally so
you can you know look me up we can get
coffee there we go ari i want to thank
you so much um it's just been so great
it's been such a pleasure i've learned
so much particularly um all about energy
i'm still fascinated by the point you
made about um it being unconstitutional
to ban bitcoin i've actually written
that down so i'm gonna go do some
research on that
um but yeah i want to thank you so much
it's been great my pleasure thank you
for having me
absolutely and guys thank you so much
for tuning in thank you to the sponsors
and we'll see you all
next week on thursday bye
[Music]
[Applause]